what led you Frank to uncover the
mystery of of jodorowsky soon well it
was really just hearing hearing the the
Nugget of the idea I mean if you were if
you're familiar with alejandro
jodorowsky at all and you know those
wiles movie is that he made and then you
kind of learn oh he was gonna make dune
before David Lynch did that's really
weird and then not only was he you know
his projects die every day and what's
really left but you know maybe a couple
of screenplay drafts but this was a
completely realised film in a book form
it's it's wild and you look at the more
we learned about it the team has team of
spiritual warriors his amazing cast of
his amazing cast of actors Pink Floyd
coming in to do the music just it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and then
once I saw an image of that book I knew
that I mean I just needed to see inside
of it I don't know if it would be a
movie I didn't know what but I know that
I needed to see inside that book and the
only way to see inside that book was to
find to find the guy himself and speak
to him who's whose philosophy I feel
like really fulfills it the whole story
I mean he's a you know as he says he's a
very spiritual filmmaker not in a
religious sense not in a in a God that's
spoken about specifically but he his
goal was to change the world he wanted
the film to be a prophet he wanted to
change all the young minds of all the
world and that is what happened I mean
the world was changed whether his movie
ended up on the big screen in 1976 or
whether it ended up in the big screen to
this documentary his idea still got out
permeated into the world and changed the
course of history a spiritual war the
spiritual warrior is the idea that I
love is that he has got both old and new
guard of avant garde in there he's got
Orson Welles
he's got Salvador Dali and then he's
also got magma and Pink Floyd and Mick
Jagger and he's got you know Chris Foss
and he's got Geiger I think that he just
sees something or meet someone and knows
that they are the person you know and
the perfect example in the film is of
course you know him
you know douglas trumbull did 2001 he's
the greatest special effects guy I must
go find him and then he goes to find him
and realizes that douglas trumbull is
not his spiritual warrior but who is his
spiritual warrior but Dan O'Bannon the
guy that had made done the special
effects on Dark Star which is
essentially john carpenter's thesis film
from USC sat with him for several
several years over the course like the
three weeks here through Xterra things
like yeah we shot through we trapped
with him throughout 2011 2012 into 2013
kind of going back and forth he lives in
Paris so we were just going back and
forth getting more information go shoot
an interview with somebody else go back
to him kind of you know corroborate the
evidence and and see what he had to say
so the more time we got to spend with
him the better it is the does he still
have that amazing book that that he that
I guess I made it probably but what a
dozen or sold and they said that they
brought them to studios that they made
some for every studio so I'm guessing at
that time 75 about a dozen or so give or
take does he still have that original
one oh he has I mean the original one
that he has is the one that's that's in
the film so that one exists Michelle
Sidhu recently found one in his mother's
house as he was cleaning it out after
she passed away he found it hidden in a
closet somewhere so that's - and in the
research for the film we found on eBay
that a copy had sold to a Japanese
collector about ten years ago or so but
we couldn't find anybody because both of
the eBay usernames are extinct but
somebody in Japan has a third one but I
think when this film is released we're
gonna start hearing about people finding
it in attics and in different studio
executives desk drawers and stuff would
the film had the film been made do you
think that it had it flopped had it not
flopped you think it would have had the
same impact the same DNA strand running
through 35 years of cinema that it does
now having not been made do you think
they would have had the same impact well
I it would have a different impact I
don't think that if the film had been
made I don't think that other filmmakers
could take those ideas and put them into
their films because they would be called
out for sure but there's the you know
there's all the there was the universe
and then there was the most
and there's different timelines and
there's the timeline that we're living
in which is Jodorowsky's dune did not
make it to the big screen and then there
was the timeline let's say where his
dune does make it it did make it to the
big screen and let's say that it was a
huge success
let's say it was the biggest movie of
1976 what would that mean for the film
studios would they think oh these were
these weird avant-garde films or
something we can get behind and make a
lot of money on and if so what would
film history look like and if his dune
had come out and been a disaster let's
say six people had seated and everyone
said it was horrible they all walked out
what would that mean because at that
same time is when George Lucas and Gary
Kurtz were making Star Wars at Fox and
Fox was already not behind Star Wars
they thought it was stupid all this
movies never going to make any money
they were looking for any excuse to pull
that plug
and if Jodorowsky's giant budgeted
sci-fi space opera had been a flop that
would have been the perfect excuse for
Fox to pull the plug on the other giant
sci-fi science fiction space opera and
without Star Wars coming out for better
or for worse what does that do to the
timeline of film history what would the
big films be what would the big tentpole
films be every summer they certainly
wouldn't be movies aimed at kids maybe
they would be films aimed at us alright
the room with review is coming out this
summer alright part three bring your
kids right four three you know in his
mind he made the picture as he said I
make the pictures you know all of his
designs everything is in the book he
said I said I did the hard part and that
was the easy part make it an animation
make a feature film of it use it as a
blueprint so he has no I don't think he
ever gives it a second thought because
even he took his own ideas and as he
says put them into comics put them into
into other films that these are the
people who make alien and without alien
you know they've had a lien that been
made there'd be no Blade Runner no Blade
Runner no aliens everything like that no
matrix things there's a there's a ripple
effect across everything you know is its
stated in the film but it's true like
all all these roads really lead
back to Jodorowsky because even taking
Blade Runner I mean how influenced how
influential is alien how influential is
Blade Runner Blade Runner came from
Jodorowsky's dune Blade Runner came from
Dan O'Bannon and Mobius meeting on dune
writing a comic book together called the
lone to the long tomorrow and if you
look at the long tomorrow it is Blade
Runner it's exactly those that setting
that cityscape the way it's built that
comes from the long tomorrow because
Mobius and Dan O'Bannon showed it to
Ridley Scott he gave it to Syd Mead and
often to film history it went so really
all these things even things we couldn't
touch on in this film come back to to
this event in history he just basically
pulled out of thin air as he said that
he never you know at the time that he
agreed to make the film he had never
read the book he was just trying to make
money he was to live he was living in
New York and he had made El Topo and he
had made a holy mountain and he was
working with a producer named Allen
Klein and Allen Klein funded the holy
mountain and Allen Klein to follow up
the whole amount the holy mountain
wanted jodorowsky to direct a story of
Oh which was essentially if you don't
know the story bow it's like that's like
the Fifty Shades of Grey of the mid-70s
and and jurasky didn't want to direct
that so he just called up Michelle Sidhu
who had released his films to success in
France and said I want to make a movie
with you and Michelle said what do you
want to make dune just to get on the
plane he said I could have said Hamlet I
could have said Don Quixote I could have
said Romeo and Juliet but he said dude I
don't think that he would equate his
experience on dune with with the lost in
La Mancha documentary because that's a
real I think in Jonah's eyes that's a
real failure you know poor Terry Gilliam
was out in the desert shooting every
kind of calamity incan tast Rafi he
happened to shut down the production
which left them with a bunch of
half-full reels of film while you know
jodorowsky really feels that this is not
a failure this is a grand success
look at the wonderful thing that I
created and maybe it wasn't meant to
happen maybe it was just meant to for
them all to create all this beautiful
artwork and for it to end right
they're in this book those ideas still
go out into the universe through the
pages of the book through his spiritual
warriors and then maybe I'm the last
spiritual warrior and I came along 40
years later and and approached him and
finished the process of getting those
ideas out into the world and getting the
full story out into the world but I was
watching a video of him shot two years
ago in Spain where he's speaking before
an audience of 6,000 people and he's in
this kind of theater-in-the-round and
walking around the stage and he was 80
just two years ago so he was 83 at the
time but I look at that video I see a
man of no older than 50 and he has his
power over the entire audience and he
has the entire audience crossed their
arms and and hold each other's hands so
6,000 people in this beautiful theater
all around him all grasp each other's
hands and swaying back and forth like
the movement of an ocean while humming
and it's the most extraordinary and it's
just him speaking in Spanish and I
didn't understand the warrant but I
understood everything because you
understand him he comes across
he's international he's a citizen of the
world it's the most extraordinary video
he was a 83 year old man commanding an
audience of every age and and he's
reborn when he tells these stories he he
will not he will live to be 300 years he
will outlive us all because as he says
he's always creating he's always doing
something he has more things to do you
only die when you stop he's like a shark
he just keeps moving keeps moving and
keeps creating because he was very
hands-off during the process and he let
me tell the story which is amazing
because it's such a personal story to
him but he really let some Yahoo like me
come in and and tell the story but you
know he we were a kin and he was gonna
see the film for the first time we were
in the theater and I was sitting here
and his wife was next to me and then
Johto was in the next year I think he
wanted a buffer in between us because he
didn't know what to expect and so all
during the film I'm kind of you know
nervously watching it and I kept trying
to look out of the corner of my eye
enough you know slick fashioned
see is he asleep is he laughing is he
enjoying it is he contacting his lawyer
is he gonna sue me what's gonna happen
and I kept trying to watch I could see
that he was really engrossed really
engrossed and then at the end I you know
in the last words of the film I could I
looked over and I see both he and his
wife are wiping tears away which is
always great because you always want to
make an 85 year old man cry I felt so
good about myself but I hear you know
okay so I waited for the credits to roll
and the lights came back up and I leaned
forward and I said so so what did you
think and he just turned to me and said
it's perfect